there is a criminal
in los angeles
who is very very happy today
uh this is
a criminal with a long rap sheet with
gang affiliations this is a murderer
this guy is going to have face
far lower charges
than he otherwise would have because
there is a george soros backed very
liberal district attorney in los angeles
who's letting criminals off the hook and
he was just recorded on a phone call
with his attorneys this this not the d.a
but the criminal and he says i'm gonna
have to clean up some of this language
because i'm gonna get canceled if i use
some of these words
he says i'm gonna get that n-word's name
on my face that's a champ right there
effin gascon
that's gang member luis angel hernandez
uh talking about the d.a george gascon
this s-h-i-t looking real good he says
in a phone call now we got a new da in
la so they're going to drop a gang of uh
like my gun enhancement my gang
enhancement my gang enhancement is 10
years full
for being a gang member do i sound
convincingly like a gang member i don't
know i've got to i'll have to work on my
performance just like taylor lorenz at
wapo needs to work on her performance
whining about boxing i'll have to work
on mine as being a gang banger
my gang enhancement is 10 years fool and
then the gun in the commission of a
crime that's the n word right there bro
he's making historic changes for all of
us fool i'm just grateful fool like i
got good news off that s-h-i-t they're
like you coming home blood
they already told me my lawyer already
told me you're coming home
this is being reported by fox news it
almost reads like it's out of a cartoon
i have actually have trouble believing
that this guy is saying it except that
the d.a really is letting these people
off the hook
and and the the gang banging psychopaths
are they might be total lunatics but
they know where their bread is buttered
they know where they owe their debts and
this guy owes a great debt of gratitude
to george gascon because as a result of
george gascon's
policies as district attorney you're
going to get a lot more
crazy
murderous
gangster psychos on the streets that's
the effect so more people are going to
get hurt more people are going to get
killed more innocent people more
innocent taxpayers citizens of los
angeles are going to wind up the victims
of violence
because this district attorney would
rather prioritize
luis angel hernandez
and and would rather prioritize his
interests over the interests of the
people who want to remain safe
there was a recall attempt against this
d.a
it didn't work it's very hard to recall
people
but i it's hard to see
how this plays very well and
so why is he doing it why is this
district attorney letting these breaking
bad level caricatures of psychos off the
hook
he's doing it one part ideologically
because the left believes that the only
reason that bad people do bad things is
because society has somehow failed them
and so actually it's our fault it's
never the criminal's fault it's always
the victim's fault it's victim blaming
in its purest form that's the
ideological reason why this is happening
but then the raw political reason why
this is happening is because chaos
breeds opportunity for the libs this is
why they always want to upend not just
our standards and mores and traditions
but law and order itself civil society
itself this is why the left encouraged
the blm riots this is why the left this
is why kamala harris the sitting vice
president raised money to bail out the
most violent people in the george floyd
riots
is because when there's violence on the
streets when when buildings are burning
when the law is not being enforced when
the cops are being defunded when whole
police departments are being abolished
that gives the left much more
opportunity to tinker with society a
society that they they believe that they
can remake through their own unfettered
reason
that's why this is happening it's not an
accident it's not just that the d.a is
incompetent it's that he's a radical and
he's getting exactly what he wants
i'm glad you like that clip now ring the
bell subscribe get all the notifications
don't miss a single one unless youtube
doesn't send them to you which you know
listen i've heard sometimes so if you
want to make sure you get all the
notifications go to the audio podcast
spotify stitcher google play apple
podcasts wherever you get your audio
podcast for free subscribe to the
michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you